[Música]
cánticos ancestrales inundan el centro
de San Pablo
la capital económica de Brasil es el
cuarto municipio con la mayor población
indígena Aquí viven 13.000 de los cerca
de 900.000 nativos que habitan este
extenso país país
[Música]
Esta es una de las principales el
líderes indígenas de Brasil
en 2018 disputó la vicepresidencia al
lado del izquierdista guillerme bolos
pero obtuvieron menos del 1% de los
votos
este año Sonia pretende conquistar uno
de los 513 escaños de la cámara baja en
total hay 186 candidatos indígenas para
nosotros No importa la cantidad lo que
queremos es calidad y representantes que
puedan ser elegidos es importante tener
candidaturas viables en todos los
estados federados y que tengan consensos
hoy en el congreso solo hay una diputada
indígena huapichana el objetivo para la
próxima legislatura es crear un grupo
parlamentario que pueda defender desde
la capital los intereses de las 256
etnias que existen en Brasil
los afrodescendientes que son mayoría en
Brasil también buscan una mayor
representatividad por primera vez en la
historia hay más candidatos negros que
blancos
Renata creció en una Favela de Río de
Janeiro y consiguió estudiar periodismo
en esta universidad la mejor de la
ciudad gracias a una beca hoy es una
reconocida defensora de los derechos
humanos y aspira su segundo mandato
lo que cambia en el proceso electoral de
Brasil es justamente la posibilidad de
que negros y negras tengan acceso a los
fondos y recursos de los partidos
este fue un cambio significativo para
que las personas negras pudiesen
presentar sus candidaturas
sin embargo los partidos no han
destinado todos los fondos establecidos
por la justicia electoral para afros y
mujeres Todavía queda un largo camino
hacia la paridad